I just said to Matt losing would suck
and winning would be really scary and
it's really really scary
um you know we're we're just really two
young guys who were fortunate enough to
be involved with a lot of great people
whom it's coming upon us to there's no
way we're doing this in less than 20
seconds
of us to thank
um Gus Van santz for brilliant Direction
Robin Williams who delivered to straight
lines many driver whose performance his
brain stealing skarsgarden was great
your brother um my brother Casey who's
brilliant in the movies Cole house or my
mother and Matt's mother the most
beautiful women here my dad right over
there and um Jack said hi to you and uh
John Gordon from here Chris
Patrick whites are the best agent in
Hollywood yeah Patrick
um all our friends have came and
everybody back in Boston watching us and
thank you so much the city of Boston and
and and God I know we're forgetting
somebody whoever we forgot we love you
and we love you thank you thank you so
much